all right today's question comes from
jennifer in alabama
jennifer writes our daughter has been
struggling with college for a couple of
years
she's seeing a therapist for anxiety and
depression she recently decided to drop
out of school and work full time
she refuses to move back home and wants
to keep the car
we provided her for school we told her
to come home figure out her next steps
and give the car back or she can finish
school and keep the car
she sees this as a punishment and thinks
we are unsupportive villains
any advice on how to keep a 21 year old
who seems to have already
already made up their mind
dave you're a dad who's had a couple of
three or four 21 year olds
i've got some man
this one gets under my skin a little bit
so you go first
um i don't think
jennifer that you're involved enough in
her
situation emotionally
uh to meet out this boundary
it sounds like you don't believe that
she has anxiety and depression and she's
just screwing around and so you're gonna
punish her for screwing around
um that's the way this sounds to me so
if you're acting on that
then that's okay if she really has
anxiety and depression and you really
believe she does then you're completely
out of line
give her the car help her she's trying
to find her way through
a real tough mental situation
and you know but i i think you guys are
pretty detached from her emotional is
what it feels like
yeah the note i wrote is this is a
relationship issue right now yeah
and you're trying to flex on a 21 year
old who's struggling
and sometimes for a college student
with obviously with high expectations
and high family support to say
i'm gonna take a break that's a hard
brave move
it's not always the best and sometimes
people are into drugs and crazy but
sometimes it's a hard brave move
and this looks like oh well then you can
just
fill in the blank and you know what as a
parent you can do that that's your car
you can do that
and obviously but your question was how
to help her that's right the question
was not
what should i should i take her car away
the question was how do i help her
that's right and if this is my kid i'm
going to get on the next
bus or get in my car and we're gonna go
have a meal together
and say i'm i'm something here tells me
this is a long time coming
and um there's a there's a deeply
fractured relationship
it's just hard to hit somebody in the
back of the head unless you got your arm
around their shoulder
you know and it feels like that you're
trying to punch from over here
not from your not from your arm around
the shoulder yeah
um and when somebody's struggling and
they say hey i need to take a step back
and your first thought your first
response is then you need to do what i
say
that's hard yeah it's hard and at the
same time i want to be clear
this is your car come get it but it may
cost you
your daughter yeah your question was not
what your rights are your question was
how can i
um help guide
a 21 year old who's already made up
their mind right
um i think i you know
i'm going to do a i i'm reading a lot
between the lines it's hard to know in
this situation
but i'm reading a lot between the lines
that your relation your emotional
connectivity and relationship with her
is not deep enough to make the to make
to to she's not listening to you
and that tells me you don't have enough
connectivity for her you're not
persuading
anymore you're just you're just hitting
with a bat you're not even a safe place
enough
safe enough place to come home when
she's falling apart
right she's got to go find somewhere
else we we talk a lot about boomerang
kids who
can't wait to run back to mom and dad
and you know there's a whole industry
about teaching mom and dad how to draw
boundaries
but kids think that mom and dad are safe
in that situation your kid's struggling
and she doesn't you are not a place that
she can even be around now she wants to
keep your car fair enough
you're not a place that she can go and
that's where the car the car doesn't
matter
no that's what i think um they get
advice on how to help guide her and
spend more time with her
right and this looks like help guides
listen more and talk less how do i flex
more yeah
how do i listen more and talk less and
um
gain the emotional proximity
earn the right to persuade and guide and
that's great
you've lost this right that's what we're
both saying she's lost the right to
persuade
yeah that's what amounts to for sumps
through something we don't know what
and my guess is this is a long time it
could be the kid yeah it could be the
kid but somehow you lost the right to
persuade so
keep the car don't keep the car i don't
give a rip about the car um get in your
car and go sit down and meet you if it's
if it's not an expensive car just give
it to her i wouldn't give her any more
money
until we've got these things repaired
she's a 21 21 year old making a 21 year
old grown-up decision so she can go make
her 21-year-old
life yeah i'll go along with that and
i'm not going to support things that i
don't have
that i can't speak into uh so if you're
gonna wall me out
for whatever reason my fault or your
fault then i'm not gonna throw money in
over the wall that's not uh that that's
just uh
that's enabling on a steroids but but if
you throw the car
into the mix and then use that as a
leverage to just start to rebuild
a higher quality relationship to
persuade
that's your only help i think as a dad
of kids
grump having grown kids is the most
difficult version of kid raising kids oh
man
because you no longer get to tell them
what to do no you have to persuade them
and so i have to sit with my son who's
getting ready to turn 30 and talk him
into stuff like i have to talk you into
stuff
you know i can't just make you do well i
can as your boss
but then it's the same thing it's a
temporary thing so i have to persuade
adults in my life to do things that are
even for their own good
whether they're my kids as adults or
other people's kids as adults and so
you just cannot you and it was just
easier when i said you have to do that
because i said so
i read a line the other day dave that
i'm still processing and it and when i
hear a line like this i'll sit on it for
a while
but here was the line i want to be the
kind of father that when something
happens to my child he doesn't think
oh crap we can't tell dad
we can't let dad find out i want to be
the kind of dad that when something
happens to my kid
he says oh crap we better find dad we
better call dad and
not that that means that we're not going
to hold people accountable but i want to
be
the the sentiment behind this is i want
to be a safe enough place that my kid
trusts me that when things get sideways
i'm going to walk alongside him
and i haven't wrapped my head around
that yet that might kill me but he'll
help me
first that's right that's right
that's right that's the dad i want to be
i do want the threat of death over them
he'll do it quick and painless right
this one's going to be slow and
miserable right yeah
yeah but there's something about
building that safety as a parent that
i'm going to hold you accountable but
you're never
ever going to doubt that i love you yeah
and that's a hard balance right yeah
that's exactly right it's a and i think
it's even harder the older they get
yeah when they're three you know you
just make them do stuff
is it okay so let me ask you this dave
is it hard because you have a desired
future
for them or is it hard because because i
like people doing what i tell them to do
yeah you're letting the control go right
that seems to be the hard part
yeah i mean we all do it's like i told
you
you know listen if you turn left there
you're going you're not going to get the
where you're going you need to turn
right yeah it's and then i have to
then when they go around the block six
times i told you you know it's like
you keep driving a car like that you're
going to wreck it you know you keep
driving your life like that you're going
to wreck it and
sure enough they do you know and but uh
you can't
and the only way we learn stuff is about
wrecking the card no it's not the only
way you can watch other people
i know you can listen to your own man
who wrecked a bunch of cars and knows
better
you know you don't have to go broke to
learn to not do what i did to go broke
you can you can
you can do better